gravity rushes physics-defying gameplay
attracted a following when it arrived on
vita in 2012 and now it's found a second
win on playstation 4 in a remastered
version that both looks and plays better
than the original gravity rush offers an
intriguing lead character cat who can
manipulate gravity at will this power
allows her to float walk on ceilings
carry heavy objects and fall in any
direction almost as if she could fly you
take control of her after she wakes up
with amnesia in the whimsical city of
hex Ville which was torn apart by a
gravitational disturbance separating
neighborhoods from one another and
introducing alien like enemies known as
nevi cat and a likable cast of non
playable characters keep you firmly
engaged in hex bills current events
where a reasonable person may succumb to
confusion cat finds her footing quickly
realizing that she can use her powers to
help those in need
happily slipping on the guise of his
superhero she earns a reputation around
town and is eventually called away from
small acts of kindness to tend to hex
bills brand or problems cat keeps a
positive demeanor but she's also quick
to acknowledge when people are being
greedy odd or otherwise abnormal which
helps to flesh out her personality cat's
abilities undoubtedly carry gravity rush
they're easy to execute but difficult to
master tap a button to free yourself
from gravity aim the camera and hit the
same button again to direct gravity and
send cat forward she can remain in the
state of gravitational flux as long as
her power meter lasts but by exploring
the world and collecting gems she can
cash in an upgrade numerous aspects of
her skill set though you start as an
awkward superhero with limited abilities
your powers grow and becomes second
nature by the end of the game
gravity rush is filled with captivating
sights and it bears a charming aesthetic
that fili resembles Hayao Miyazaki's
illustrative style you don't spend a lot
of time on the ground an effect of
falling in love with cats aerial
exploits but you do get to experience
heck spills or neat structures from on
high clipping its tallest buildings
walking upside down on the floating
city's underbelly and gawking at dreamy
silhouettes against the city's orange
green and blue skies these views are
better now than before with the
remastering process adding new geometry
and sharper textures as well as
increasing the resolution to 1080p and
the frame rate to 60 frames per second
tumbling through the air and witnessing
the world around you are persistent joys
and it helps that you venture to
otherworldly dimensions from time to
time each offering their own wonders but
the missions you undertake be they story
missions or optional challenge missions
fail to trigger excitement you regularly
have to navigate to specific points in
hex field to obtain an item or fight a
group of enemies and that's about it
early combat and gravity rush kicks off
on the ground where cat can combo into
enemies with a series of kicks and evade
incoming attacks with a quick burst of
speed you quickly realized however that
you are more effective when attacking
from midair dive kicking into enemies
unfortunately enemies big and small are
taken down with the exact same strategy
point your reticle and enemies glowing
white spot and trigger your dive kick
you have access to a few special attacks
that are tied to a cool-down meter but
these just help you get the job done
faster offering little in the way of
newfound satisfaction during combat when
you're in raptured with gravity rushes
mechanics world and characters time
flies by because of this it's a bit of a
letdown when the game ends and the story
that guided you along a path filled with
new wondrous opportunities comes to a
screeching halt without a clear
resolution as we now know gravity rush 2
is in production and will continue the
tale told here but that fact doesn't
make up for the unsatisfactory ending
gravity rush comes off as formulaic at
times but it's also a wonderful Joyride
that's been enhanced by a generous free
mastering effort that makes it feel
right at home on PlayStation 4 it's an
adventure worth taking not just because
there's hardly anything like it but
because it gleefully frees you from the
hold of gravity in a world worth explore
you